a man arrested in connection with a mass
shooting over the weekend appearing
before a judge claiming to be a victim
himself the shooting happened saturday
at manny's glow ultra lounge a hookah
bar and restaurant on sahara right near
maryland parkway according to court
records 44-year-old lee wilson is no
stranger to southern nevada's law
enforcement
44 year-old lee frank wilson was brought
into court thursday in a wheelchair also
covering his face he claims he was shot
six times last weekend the state has
filed a criminal complaint charging you
with murder with use of deadly weapon
and 12 counts of attempt murder with use
of deadly weapon all felony offenses the
hookah lounge has yet to reopen police
say a fight at the bar turned into a
shooting 33-year-old demetrius beard
died and 13 others were injured in court
a deeper look at wilson's past mr wilson
does have a significant prior history it
appears that according to pre-trial
services he does have 82 local arrests
dating back to 1995 nine prior felony
convictions
including convictions for
escape according to records from the 8
news now i-team wilson's arrest not only
happened in the city of las vegas but
also in north las vegas and henderson
for crimes of stolen property domestic
violence and assault with a deadly
weapon
before this weekend's shooting wilson
was recently released from prison
according to those records he faced
charges in connection with attempted
murder of two people he was sentenced to
12 months in prison christian casa is
live local now
the judge ordered wilson be held without
bail and scheduled back in court he'll
be back in court on march 21st